[Music]
in come on man
news come on come on man
submitted by machi yato a man who was
arrested for stealing his own car is set
to win a one point two five million
dollar settlement because he caught the
stealer why are we rewarding him here
was he like beaten up and someone caught
him or whatever they're like he's good
and his men hate these stories where
people just fall on money whose money -
so he stole his own car and got rewarded
for it maybe he paid himself so this man
was arrested by Illinois police because
there was this woman who saw this PhD
student named Lawrence who's 25 when the
incident happened back in 2015 he was
trying to fix something on his car so
this woman called the cops because she
thought that he was stealing the car so
when the cops got there they beat his
ass they did damn it they beat him have
a dash cam footage no that's why no so
her neighbor called the cops on him or
wherever he was yeah is this guy a
minority and the lady's a white lady
uh-huh might happen yeah my buddy says
let this person be a white dude so I
don't want no racial tension
[Applause]
many people they're all well what are
they doing he's hella peaceful what are
you doing percent compliant
dude that guy was throwing fists now
what are you doing dude yeah he gets one
point you know totally fun maybe ten
more 3-car they had nothing better to do
that I've seen a way more aggressive
dudes get taken down with less dudes and
then way safer way dude that legit look
like a [ __ ] piranha tank and somebody
dropped a piece of meat in it that was
horrible what the [ __ ] was this a
complaint what the head his hands up
every it's more high - they weren't even
like yeah like your sigh he's like I
don't know what happened
that's fine they should pick each one of
those police officers and put them in a
punching bag hang them like the new UFC
performances didn't let Mike Tyson come
and practice on them but that is [ __ ]
that was so unnecessary dude that guy in
the red was just going like this over
and over let me go to jail you know cops
never do jail time for that [ __ ]
but the city has to know Pam one point
what where did this happen Illinois and
what Sid tey cuz I know there's a lot of
crime in chickenstein City I don't know
what area but question would you get
jumped like that by a bunch of cops for
1.25 yeah I would do it too and he
didn't it didn't look that bad when you
dangle 1.2 million I got [ __ ] up
harder than that I think I mean yeah
yeah there nobody did he get any like
broken bones or anything like that no
well he got was one point two five mil
he self to pay taxes on that like a game
show for settlement freakin elements
like income yeah got it that would be a
funny game show though where you have to
get beat up by cops and then you get you
win this big check but you have like a
black eye like missing teeth that sounds
like a so tragic but one point to twenty
grand fixes all that [ __ ] and all that
stuff you might even get those bad baby
[ __ ] teeth you might even get better
payoff is medical or schooling oh what a
shitty [ __ ] world we live in we're
like oh please would you [ __ ] get
[ __ ] I'm like yeah I actually would I
get tasered how big gives me two million
and I'll get a little bit one there so
the officers determined that he was an
owner of the car at the scene before
they attack them no no oh but then
they've detained him for disobeying
police and resisting arrest
no they detained him because they didn't
know what to do after they [ __ ] up
thank God for dashcam footage because it
would have been so easy to be like yeah
he drew this gun on this I know all
right
oh and I said medical my bad yeah no
yeah my bad okay how you gonna beat up
somebody smart - yeah I know yeah I have
stupid people they can't defend I could
see two places were where why the police
reacted this way now this is not to
justify their actions by any means but I
always like to think of reasons why
because it's not like people go you know
become a police officer and go you know
what I want to beat up black people you
know like that's not that's highly
highly unlikely like it that that even
that sentiment it develops right how did
that happen well I think there's two
cases where this can happen like and it
can happen over and over again one is
it's a small town with not much action
so when things do happen
you got the whole entire police force
overreacting because they don't know how
the [ __ ] to react to this situation
another one is recently if there was a
police that got murdered
everyone's on high alert and it's like
if this is in Chicago there's a huge
crime rate and a murder rate so like
these guys might be extra paranoid
because they're thinking this guy's
might be armed or whatever doesn't even
justify the action but then it's like if
people don't figure out the root cause
of these problems none of these problems
will ever get fixed I
I saw that footage i legit thought I was
gonna see somebody come out the side of
the screen with the elbow
yeah we're [ __ ] having a field day on
that kid but then like the split second
before they attacked him he did turn
around and look like I mean maybe in
their minds like he was gonna try to run
away or somewhat hands up though I guess
if you see it again you do see him like
kind of turn around so I'm not
justifying them beating them up at all
but as a cop who knows I'm gonna see it
turn around - yeah so you DS been
following directions also sure you're
like in in shell-shocked kind of mode
yeah the well they're all young [ __ ]
seven different things
[ __ ] it Blake what do you want to do
just like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and in the hand
did go here so that that that might have
made him go scared but you know but he
he was he was comply but there was no
leader who will [ __ ] was paper dead
degree homie Dan also like crazy after
the first few punches and someone's on
the ground and you and several of the
people on definitely your side or on top
of them like you don't need the extra
stuff like what you were saying you know
like I I can respect trying to find the
root of the problem that makes sense we
have to have these kinds of
conversations but like who from any
angle can justify the continued
oh no that's a clear sign of abuse and
abuse of power and I mean yeah I mean
like I said I've seen crazier more
aggressive actual like guys that were
attacking the police with less cops and
the way that they tackled and dealt with
the arm yeah yeah the way that they
dealt with them was nowhere near this
this is like
sickness buzz I was like a football
tackle and the whole damn team jumped
onto it it's like they all wanted to
show each other that their they were all
that they all had big dicks that's what
it seemed that [ __ ] yeah how many
[ __ ] means do you need to keep this
kid down yeah the guy with the red shirt
definitely had the smallest dick so
gotta like prove it like I got a big
dick look is there a job is to
neutralize so the minute you neutralize
a situation it's done you don't have to
keep throwing elbows or knees or
anything like that
yeah it was pretty excessive that's why
I'm like I'm 1.25 mil for a quick
beatdown that's why you focus thoughts
but then what it's like also arrested
him though
yeah does anything go on is right why me
absolutely not enough to that make more
than conger me at that moment
no I'm saying like if things are good
now like he they're clear [ __ ] these
guys let me show you something that's so
sad I'm not saying I'm happy for him I'm
saying Lauren I think oh you graduated
he's a wizard too you know Renaissance s
wizard dude ain't no Flom ravenclaw well
he's all these lawyers he's gonna be a
lawyer so he's a doctor doctor in what
dr. Lawrence doctor and a Sportster
Crosby Oh dr. Crosby millionaire because
remember that's tight you just got a
pretty you dude you all we met at
Northwestern northwestern is a
prestigious a school - this will smart
Northwestern career college you can do
it he's a smart guy
we're engineering in jammu yeah dance
bulls Bethy he's already balling on top
of ball and he was driving his car to
the lab to do some work and this woman
followed him oh she this boy she stalked
him yeah call the police wait what what
like why did she think this dude was
still in the car in the first place cuz
B do you have a key that he put in and
in home
so remember I said he was fixing
something from his car so he was picked
from his house he said - right yeah so
he was at home and his neighbor that's
where she yeah pretty much what a [ __ ]
back so then he was trying to fix a
loose part on his car and so she thought
that he was jimmying the door Wow so
then he he gets in the car and in that
she follows him yeah and then she wall
she's following him she calls the police
so she should be in trouble for stalking
they need they should put her as one of
those clowns in the rodeo for like just
three three rounds
but let's say he really he was stealing
the car that she's a good citizen then
right yeah what maybe think that just
seeing someone repair a car like say his
race had been different and he was out
to repair your car would she be like ah
the two men were paying a car would it
be like thief this is the sad part right
so it's like you know there's a
situation where somebody says or
somebody like him he does everything
right in life right yeah everything
right in life you can't even pin
anything to the guy that guy is a
well-educated man yeah but it boils down
to a skin colour with a woman who felt
afraid of this guy because of what he
looked and he got asked before and how
does that make you feel as an individual
look I do everything right but still I'm
still that black dude that's about to
steal a car and that's like the sad part
yeah
and this is the both extremes - like
he's a doctor
yeah and he's still being considered a
criminal he's like what do I have to do
to prove that I'm a good upright citizen
it's like what the [ __ ] yeah that's
crazy
she should go to jail yeah she should be
a dartboard out of [ __ ] bar if you
are a failed tattletale and you get
someone in some deep [ __ ] [ __ ]
something should happen I think
something should happen that means you
weren't a good citizen that what that
means that you don't [ __ ] up man also
maybe meet your neighbors never saw your
neighbor once yeah I know but she
thought she's clearly peeking out the
window she followed him this guy steals
from that house every day he's stealing
the same car every single day this
[ __ ] black bastard goes into his
house and puts pictures of himself
somebody else like the Dave Chappelle
stand up dude like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]